>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Brian Ausland: Okay,
welcome to session
on Digital Collections
K-12 Classroom;
Connecting with Teachers
and Students.
It's a co-presentation by our
three respective projects.
Go ahead and do a quick
introduction.
>> Franky Abbott: I'm Franky Abbott
of the Digital Public Library
of America, and I am the Curation
and Education Strategist at DPLA,
and I have worked on our
Primary Source Sets Project.
>> Stephanie Greenhut:
And I'm Stephanie Greenhut
from the National Archives.
I'm an Education Technology
Specialist there and Project Manager
of the DocsTeach.org
project that we have.
>> Brian Ausland: And
I'm Brian Ausland.
I'm with Navigation North out of
California, and we did the research,
development, and design
of Smithsonian's new
Learning Lab system.
Okay, so we have a plan
for this presentation.
We got the first bullet done, we're
going to take a high-level response
to the five questions that we
put in our session description.
As a team, we've met
a few times and talked
about those questions respectively
to our own experience
and background.
So it's going to be kind
of a high-level thing,
and then we're going to take
time for questions to get
into more detailed information
you based on that it is
that deem important
or need to know about,
but Robert Burns said
something about plans.
Part of our plan is
this macro approach,
and then the questions let us
get into some more details,
and the reason for that is the
morals we met and talked about this.
The three of us are really not
talking about our own experience,
we're talking about the
experience of our projects.
These can all easily be their
own sessions, and so we're going
to do our best to kind of just fly
across the top of these bigger ideas
and then go where you need us to go.
So you're part of that plan.
So if you can help us
with in that last part
to let us know what you need to
know more about, and we've come
to the conclusion that if you
walk out of the room kind of clear
about what our projects respectively
tackled and try to understand and do
and what they continue to grow
and want to do, and if you find
that valuable or of use or
of need for some of the work
that you're looking at,
then really, the best thing
that could happen is you would
develop a relationship with one
of us are all of us and we can
extend the conversation beyond this
presentation to help you or
give you whatever we know
and whatever we've learned
through the process.
So we're going to start with just
a description about our projects,
very briefly, that we
are all involved with,
and we'll start with Franky.
>> Franky Abbott: Sure, so you
heard a little bit this morning
about the Prime Resource
Sets Project.
DPLA, as you know,
is a big aggregator.
We work with 1900 institutions
and 14 million items
from those institutions, and part
of the mission of DPLA is to get
that content used, and
education audiences want
to be possible audiences
that might use
of cultural heritage content online.
So we did a research year in 2014
to 2015, and then we organized
in education advisory committee
of which we have a
member in the audience.
Hi, Ella. Which is a group of 10
educators in grades 6 through 14.
They met with us.
They helped us design a
template for primary source sets
and then they helped us develop
a collection of 100 of them.
The last group of which just went
up on Monday, which is exciting.
Primary Source Sets at the DPLA are
pretty simple and I think reusable
for teachers in a variety of ways.
They are an overview.
Ten to 15 selected and curated items
from the DLA's partners'
collections,
and then a teaching guide
with inquiry-based questions
and activities that teachers can use
to employ the primary
sources in the classroom.
They're organized around topics in
US history, literature and culture,
although we've made some very
brief forays into world history
and our most recent round.
They are up online.
You can see the URL, and our project
of these three tackles some
similar issues in that it is working
with a specific group of
digital content that is online,
in this case, for multiple
institutions,
but it is by far the youngest
education effort on this panel.
So we have benefited a lot
from speaking with Stephanie
and also Brian's team of
folks at the Smithsonian.
So thanks for being
on our panel with me.
>> Stephanie Greenhut: All right,
and just to tell you a
little bit about DocsTeach.
DocsTeach is, we call the online
tool for teaching with documents
from the national archives.
As opposed to the DPLA
Primary Source Sets,
this site is kind of
a dinosaur actually.
We're in the midst of overhauling
it right now to be a little fresher,
but it's actually going to
be six years old next month,
which is pretty old for an
attractive website like this.
You can kind of get a hint
at the main components here.
It's really made up of
activities and documents,
and as you can imagine, the
documents here are coming
from the holdings of
the national archives.
You've probably heard little bit
about the National Archives today,
but we're an independent agency.
We have billions of records from
all three branches of government.
One of the things that we
try and do for DocsTeach,
which is a site geared at teachers
to be able to use for, you know,
to come up with teaching
materials for their students.
We don't take all of the digitized
records that we have in the holdings
of the National Archives.
Our online catalog has thousands
and thousands and thousands more,
but what we're trying to
do is really pick the ones
that we think would be useful tools
for the classroom, and so we sort
of curate the set in a way.
It also would tend to be most
useful and a history classroom,
but there certainly are some
materials that could cross
over to world history, to language
arts, even foreign language.
We do have some records
that fit there.
We have, on the other side
of things, the activities.
It's kind of a tool
wok tour teachers.
I always use -- describe it sort of
like food or cooking, if you will.
We have these activities on the
site where if you are a teacher,
and you know, just like now,
you're on your way home after work,
and you don't feel like
putting together a dinner.
You stop, you pick up take
out or something pre-made
and it's ready to go,
just like that.
You can come, find activities
that are ready to use,
use them in your classroom with
your students, but sometimes,
you go the semi-homemade route.
So, you might, you know,
make some mac & cheese
and slip some broccoli in there.
Excuse me, I have a toddler.
So I'm always slipping in
things like that, but, you know,
so what you can do on this
side as a teacher, if you come,
you can find an activity
that you like,
but then you can modify
it to fit your needs.
So you might change the primary
sources that are involved,
swap out the instructions.
That kind of thing.
Or you can go from scratch and
use one of the tools that we have
on the site to make
your own entirely
from scratch new online activities,
and while the activities
have their own unique URL
that students can do online or
teachers can project it to use
in the classroom, that
kind of thing.
So we've got the online sites, and
then we developed an app, as well,
that students can actually
use to do the activities
that their teachers have either
found or created for them.
So that's DocsTeach in a nutshell.
Brian.
>> Brian Ausland: I didn't advance.
I didn't --
>> Stephanie Greenhut:
Oh, I'm sorry.
I totally forgot.
>> Brian Ausland: Because
if you could explain this.
>> Stephanie Greenhut: Sure,
yeah, sorry about that.
>> Brian Ausland: I've got.
>> Stephanie Greenhut:
Here we click.
Yeah, so totally forgot to -- but
one of the things I wanted to point
out is we tried to put some of the
control into the teachers' hands.
We really wanted to create a
tool that teachers could use.
So here you can see sort of the
back end of teachers are able
to use these tools or templates that
we have pretty easily and quickly
to pull together activities that
can really end up varying a lot.
>> Brian Ausland: I like how
she describes her project
as old, or what it's --
>> Stephanie Greenhut: Dinosaur.
>> Brian Ausland: A dinosaur.
We actually value their project,
because we started working
with the Smithsonian on the
research, we were looking at --
the Smithsonian had a long history
of developing, internally developing
through central efforts with their
educator teams' curriculum bundles
and curriculum models for teachers
to use, and they asked us to look
and do an environmental scan
of digital resource
learning object sites
that weren't packaging the
curriculum as kind of locked
up ready to go curriculum but, in
fact, was allowing practitioners
in the field to do manipulations of
the curriculum, and at that time,
five years ago, we only
found three examples
that had any real traction
nationally,
and the primary example we
found was the DocsTeach site,
and so we approached Stephanie
and her team at that time.
We said, "Whose crazy
idea was this?"
You know, because there wasn't a lot
of research to support at the time.
So we knew they had done a
lot of that type of work.
So we just want to know like it's
a pretty bold move in this space.
So I really like to acknowledge
their work in this field,
because a lot of us have
built upon it since then.
Of course, with the Smithsonian
we also had, and we have --
is there Smithsonian
folks in the room today?
I saw Sarah's here.
Anyone else?
Okay, so Sarah, don't
share everything I say.
I'm not a Smithsonian person.
So I was a person who came
in and worked with them
that they contracted to come and
help them think through this process
and perform research
and look at data,
but I was impressed upon just the
sheer size of the bureaucracy,
and the deepness and the
long-standing cultures of control,
and really, that became, and they're
like, "So our real work is to figure
out what teachers want, and
we really quickly learned
that that wasn't the real work.
The real work was addressing
cultural shifts
that would be required to do
something similar to DocsTeach.
So just a schematic that we
developed for them at the time,
19 museums, nine research centers,
one national zoo, lots of stuff,
lots of people, lots of history,
lots of ego, lots of stuff going on,
all corridors, and so we simply came
in, and we looked at this one piece
of data which drove their work
in the beginning was they said,
well 1995 to 2014, they had a
13.16% increase in physical visitors
to their, any one of their places,
and they had 135,000 plus percent
increase in their digital visits.
So they're, like, well,
what are we doing with that?
They also received is in funding
to investigate this through Gates
at the time, which said,
we want you to do more
to make the Smithsonian's assets
more accessible to citizens
that are geographically remote from
the Smithsonian physically and are
from certain demographics and
populations within communities
that will most likely never come to
the Smithsonian in their lifetime.
So they were looking
at some of that data.
So they said, "Well, we need to make
better use of our web presence,"
and so one of their approaches,
which was the sliver of the project
that moved our way was they'll make
it really consumable and desirable
for teachers to use, and they'll
take it to kids in classrooms,
and that will be one way
to expose the Smithsonian
to a large group of
future US citizens.
They had this piece of
research which drove some
of their early efforts, and that
was they had done this investigation
piece for over two
years, and they saw
that teachers were
readily disassembling all
of their beautiful
curriculum, right?
So teachers would take all of this
valuable, structured, thoughtful,
methodically designed curriculum
and just pull it all apart.
Like, at the third grade
level in classes in Ohio,
in afterschool programs in Oregon,
and they said, "That's disturbing."
And then the teachers and the
data that we did as follow-up,
because we were monitoring this
through use data across a number
of different state platforms
at the time, the data showed
that not only were teachers taking
it apart, which they are saying,
"Well, we can deal with it.
We'll figure out how
to deal with that."
The problem was that the
teachers valued the content,
the Smithsonian content, as highly
and instructionally valuable,
was their first assertion,
the single most important
data point teachers gave us.
They found the value in
the instruction materials.
They didn't promptly disassemble
those instruction materials,
which they found valuable,
because they said, "Well,
we want to add more value to it."
So they always knew that
they could improve it.
The third thing was more disturbing
to them, and that's what we showed,
is that most of those
teachers who found value
in the instructional content and had
to do work without tools but do work
to like crop a picture
out of one of their sites
or take a paragraph information,
put it into a Word document,
rewrite it in a way that was more
accessible to their students,
it was so cumbersome to them
that they stopped using
the materials at all.
So we'd show this incredible
drop-off
where they'd come to
the systems once.
They had a 5-plus minute engagement,
and we could see what they were
doing with the system and record it,
and so to them what was
most disturbing was not
that they were modifying the
curriculum was that they found it
so cumbersome that they just
didn't come use it at all,
even when they assigned value to it.
So that was one of their
more significant findings.
We did some work from there, and
really, our work was done directly
with large groups of teachers.
We did three years of research with
teacher teams from all over the US.
We had the teachers of the
year from every single state
that we had access to for the
weeks that they were here in DC
for the teacher of the year,
trip to the White House,
etc. Pearson would pay to have
them out here a week in advance.
The Smithsonian would get to
work with them for certain hours
of the day throughout those weeks.
So we used that time
to test teachers.
That's one of the pictures
that's up there.
We worked with teachers
through that process.
We then created a field group
of teachers across the US
that had a more diverse
blue-collar approach to teachers.
Not the teachers of the
year from every state,
and from diverse communities,
and then our second line
of research was we distilled
that down to 25 teachers
who then gave us access
to their classrooms,
and from the teachers results,
which were paper-based prototypes
that then turned into technical
prototypes, which then turned
into web-based prototypes, we
actually took the prototypes
into the classrooms of these
teachers, where the teachers,
much to our amazement
and horror, said,
"You work with our kids
with your prototype."
And so we then would spend two
to four days, two hours a day,
performing projects and activities,
as designed by the teachers
with our prototype, and the teacher
said, "You should co-teach this
with us, and then you might
understand where it works
and doesn't work for the kids."
Which was very scary for lots of
people on my side of the team.
But what we ended up developing was
a system of tools that are shown
where teachers could manipulate
resources, annotate resources,
resequence them, put in
formative assessment pieces.
Students could do different
things with a high-level imagery,
mix-and-match content resources.
Teachers could roll assignments
out through the system,
and it could track that, and we
took a very low-threshold approach
that we can have the teachers
do the basic steps they do
when developing curriculum and
engaging students in formative
and summative activities, but
then we had to make it so that all
of these things, as beautiful as
the system was, and as eloquent
as the design teams
took effort to make it,
that all of this could be ported
out to things like EdModo or Canvas
by in structure or whatever
they're using locally,
since that's what they
are invested in using.
So that was the approach, and
that with our brief covering
of three-and-half years of
research and development.
>> Franky Abbott: Sure, so we would
go through the questions briefly
as a group that we promised
to address in this session.
Some of them, one of us are
going to take a little stab at,
and then others we're
going to answer
in a little bit more
of a group kind of way.
So I'm going to take question
number one, which is -- oh, yes?
>> Okay, okay.
>> Franky Abbott: Okay,
question number one.
What is the value of education
work for cultural institutions?
I feel like I'm in a pretty good
position to answer this question,
because DPLA is, of course, the
owner of none of its own content,
but we do work with lots of other
institutions, and so I do interact
with people from multiple
institutional contexts
to create the primary source
sets, and I think for all of us,
I think it's safe to say
that the big, exciting thing
about education work is use, right?
And education use, which
is a particular kind of use
in the world of copyright.
People are generally a
little bit more generous,
a little more enthusiastic
to connect their materials
with the education
audience, and also, often,
education work is a core part of
a cultural institution's mission.
So the idea of connecting with
teachers and students is a piece
of that, and finally, sometimes
the idea or the promise
of education use has, in
fact, been a rationale
for funding the digitization itself.
So the idea that when this
stuff, which is such great stuff,
is online that it will become
useful for classrooms, you know,
in the state or across the country,
is kind the part of the reason
that people embark on digitization
projects in the first place.
That's not the only reason,
but it's a valuable reason,
and so I think it's safe to
say, from a use perspective,
there's actually a tremendous
amount in education work
for cultural institutions, but it
presents a series of big challenges
which we'll talk about in the
answers to these questions, as well.
It's your turn.
>> Brian Ausland: I
took question two,
and please appreciate the amount
of time we spent researching this.
Question is, "What is the value
of this content to teachers
and students, and how
do they use it?"
That's kind of a big,
loaded question.
So bear with me on this slide.
We published three separate
folios of research on this topic,
which all can be found online
and it's really exciting reading.
I urge you to take an
opportunity to nose through it.
However, here's a distillation
of what we were looking at.
Some of the Pew studies
was our first column
of information that's Internet has
a major impact on 90% of teachers'
to access content resource
materials for their teaching.
90% of teachers are
using search engines
to find information
on a daily basis.
84% use the Internet weekly to find
content that'll engage students.
80% were using Internet weekly
to help them create lesson plans,
and this a Pew study from 2013.
So it's only gone up from there
when we did the original work
with this a year into our project.
Our findings were that
teachers needed the content
as delivered in these ways.
This type of OER with
tools that allowed them
to manage how it's
structured and delivered
to students to be flexible.
They valued that they could maximize
the use of high-quality images.
They wanted variable manipulations
with those images that weren't built
in at the time and that weren't
being released digitally for fear
of printing and copyright
infringement.
So we had to overcome
some of those hurdles,
particularly with the
National Portrait Gallery.
Tools suggested to help adapt
resources to diverse learners.
They appreciated that
they could diversify
for different learner types in
their classrooms, which typically,
a single set of curriculum couldn't
do or couldn't know how to do,
for a given teacher's kids.
They wanted to dedicate a space for
collecting and saving resources.
Some of the outcomes they were
looking for that started to get
to us that started to be more
about pedagogy involved
making content more inclusive,
increasing learner
engagement, localizing
and personalizing content
to their area.
An example we had were the teachers
in, particularly California,
but particularly in Northern
California that do a real emphasis
on Gold Rush, which they are not
going to see with a curriculum
that comes from outside
of that area to the degree
that they do that work there.
Modification to support
specific learner needs.
Diverse content types and sources,
which they typically don't have
access to, which could come
through vehicles like this.
Differentiate formative
and summative materials,
particularly the formative pieces.
They were more interested
in delivering
and creating contemporary content
that was up-to-date, timely,
something that typically
doesn't get delivered to them
in their traditional sources
of instructional information
and materials and resources,
and support non-trad
and emerging pedagogies, which
is, as Lisa's team pointed
out this morning, there's a
real shift going on in K-12
with that textbooks aren't
prepared to or structured
to support cross-disciplinary
instruction, STEM-based focus,
all the way down into the
lower elementary levels.
So they need some flexibility
to respond
to those new pedagogical shifts that
they're seeing and they're liking
and wanting to take
up on behalf of kids.
So some of the other things that we
had to point out was that the value
of the content for
the teachers was in --
some of it was just in
the digital delivery.
So the teachers are having to
have kids take high-stakes,
summative assessments in digital
environments, by and large,
and almost every state now,
moving off of paper and pencil,
and just the fact that
they could move kids
through some digital environments
and iterations of analyzing research
and content, responded to questions,
working collaboratively online,
is helping kids be more
prepared for when those types
of high-summative level events
happen later in the school year.
So that was an asset to
teachers that they could do that,
and they also said
that the students tend
to be just a little more
engaged in the use of technology
in their classrooms, and
it was giving teachers kind
of a guided vehicle to
use that in that way.
>> Franky Abbott: This
slide has less text on it
than the slide before it.
Question three, we're
going to answer
in a little bit more of a group.
"What are the most
important considerations
when designing for this audience?"
This is another really big question,
but two contributions from me
and from our experience on
the Primary Source Sets.
Number one, there is a disconnect
between the folks who organize
and describe digital collections and
the teachers who want to use them,
and some of that disconnect
appears in the way
that objects are described
in digital collections.
So the way that metadata, which
is, in the best case scenario,
pretty comprehensive, appears and
is useful to any and a variety
of audiences in the general public
is sometimes an information overload
and requires a little
bit of translation
and sometimes some
additional contextualization
to make an object useful
for the classroom.
So I think one of the biggest
roles that we play on our teams is
that with the assistance of lots
of other people and teachers is
that role of translator between
how an object is being described
and how it arrives
in the collection,
and how it might be slightly
differently described
and contextualized to put
it in an education resource.
So considering the kinds of
translation that would be required
of your digital collection
items, which again,
are not necessarily
inherently useful.
They are made useful by
education curation I would say,
and the second is probably pretty
obvious, that it's important to us
on this stage, but if you are
considering designing an education
resource project from
a digital collection,
you have to engage teachers
in your project in real ways.
So they need to be part
of a research process
for the design process it
itself or the curation process.
I think it's pretty rare
that cultural institutions
have a huge number of people
with an education background on
their staff, and if you have that,
that's terrific, but if not, there
are creative ways to incentivize,
employ, or otherwise engage
teachers in the process of thinking
through your education
project and executing it.
So that's a really
big consideration.
>> Stephanie Greenhut:
I'm really going
to piggyback on both
of those points.
I think Franky's first point
about there's this kind of idea
of translation is really
important and something
that we have seen a lot,
especially, you know,
even if it's just hiding
some of the metadata
that can be a bit overwhelming
to both teachers
and students, and providing context.
You know, we have definitely always
seen that the more that we are able
to do that, the more uptake
there is of any given resource.
I think that the second point
about engaging teachers is really
important too because there's a lot
of complexities when it comes to
the, you know, teacher population,
that are worth understanding
or trying to understand
or acknowledging when you're
creating education resources, and,
you know, I actually came from
the National Archives straight
from the classroom.
I was teaching seventh
grade and then came on board
at the National Archives, and I
can remember thinking when I left
that job, "I need to remember
that if I email these people
and they don't email me back,
not to take it personally,
because they have no time
to do it," and you know,
I've been out of the
classroom now eight years,
and I'm kind of starting
to forget a little bit.
So I do think it's
really important to bring
in that perspective,
that fresh perspective.
But, you know, but I
think that translates
into what you're designing for
teachers too, because, you know,
going back to the metadata,
teachers don't have time to weed
through a lot to get
at what they want,
and so I think the other aspect
of that is that there was a time
when it was really hard to find, you
know, if you were a history teacher,
for instance, and you want to
find some primary sources to bring
into the classroom, it was
really difficult to do that,
and it is not the case
anymore at all.
In fact, it's the opposite.
Really, I think that it's overload.
There's so much out there, and to
go to all those sites and find one
that you like best and
evaluate the different sites
and what you want to use.
I mean, it's a lot, especially
for a time-crunched
population to start with.
So I think just, you know,
our central question here
is considerations designed
for this audience.
I mean, I think if you're designing
something, what we have found that,
you know, the easier
it is the better,
and not to make any statements
about intelligence by any means,
but just the straightforwardness is
perhaps a better way to phrase it.
You know, not a million accounts.
You know, you have to take into
consideration school firewalls
and things like that, but I
think the most direct access
and the most straightforward
access can really be the best and,
you know, sometimes the cleanest
access too with maybe some
of that metadata hit and
maybe some historical context
or whatever context, whatever
topic you're teaching,
providing some of that.
So it does take a little
bit of reframing, I think,
the resources that we have.
So again, I guess kind of going back
on that, where translation, I think,
it's a theme that's come up a lot
in our conversations about this.
Go ahead, Brian.
>> Brian Ausland: So, most
important, I mean that's kind
of a hard thing to go on, and
when talking to both these ladies,
I was talking to them about making
sure your metadata is transferable
to systems like Learning Registry.
So it can go out and
propagate into the environments
that teachers are already having
promoted, and they're using it
at their state and local levels.
The game no more is -- there's no
more stake now involved in, "Well,
how do we get them
to our website to go
from those other websites
to get to our website?"
That's a losing game.
The idea is how do you get your
materials and content to make it
to where they're already trained and
adapted to use and funded to use,
and so I was looking at that talking
about, you know, do we want to talk
about metadata and discoverability,
but really, in talking to these two,
and I said what's really important,
particularly listening
to things this morning.
I changed my mind.
I said, "I'm not sure that people
recognize the transition that's
happening right now in K-12.
I just don't know."
Even in K-12, I don't think we fully
got our heads wrapped around it,
but in all reality, teachers, by
their nature, will scavenge anything
for a classroom use and for
teaching and have a rich history
and a deep-rooted inclination
in their DNA to do that
and are really emerging right now.
Policy wise, we're emerging from
20 years of very strict state
and federal policies
saying, "You may not do that.
You are subverting the
adopted curriculum,
aligned to these high-stakes
standards, which are aligned
to these high-stakes assessment."
And it ran completely contrary to
the natural processes and behaviors
of most of our highest
skilled teachers.
Our most creative teachers, and
in fact, I was telling these two
that it wasn't even three
years ago that we were working
on a state project in
California, and we put a tool
up where teachers could just go grab
what we're now calling OER, which,
I don't know what we
were calling it then.
It's like all of the sudden it's
here at its new, but we have a term
for it, OER, and we said, "Yeah,
they can assemble it and kind
of create a background for it and
kind of create a canvas for it
and put some questions there."
And we were told by the State
Academic Deputy Superintendent
at that time in California,
she said,
"You cannot have that tool in there.
We cannot actively promote
a tool that's allowing them
to build curriculum, a
third-rail curriculum,
outside of the adopted materials
that is the third largest
single expense in K-12.
You're subverting that
entire expense,
which only falls behind the
salary and facilities in K-12."
And, I mean, that was it,
and that was state to state.
That we now sit in a day where
just in the last six months,
the Federal Department of
Education has a director of OER,
and open education initiative, and
they're asking districts and states
to sign on, which are signing on in
droves, on open education and tools
that allow teachers to go find
wonderful resources as provided
by many of the agencies represented
in this room, and many others,
and build good learning exchanges
and activities for the students
that they know so well, that
they spend 180-plus days
with in groups of 20 to 30 kids.
Of course that's who we want
developing the curriculum,
and that's what teachers want
to do, and we're now in a place
where we're basically, since
probably the mid-90s, right Letha,
just saying, by the
way, you should do that
and teachers are like,
"Great, thanks.
We'll reconnect with that
inner curriculum designer."
So I just urge people to recognize
it's going to be a reawakening.
It's going to be a --
something, and in this time,
it's very different
than 20 years ago.
There's so much from
them to select from.
If you thought teachers could do
some incredibly sophisticated,
crazy tapestries with
just the things
at their physical fingertips is
what looked like when I was still
in the classroom, what we're giving
them access to now is going to be
of incredible benefit to our
students and our learners,
if we help them with that and give
them tools to guide that process.
>> Stephanie Greenhut: All right,
so I didn't realize I was
being a bit subversive
when I was teaching but, you know,
so we wanted to talk a little bit
about what this means to put this
kind of control in teachers' hands.
You know, what about
handing materials
over to the teachers is
sort of raw materials
and seeing what they come up with?
And it's sort of, you
know, I think it's a bit
of a trick question really.
I don't think we're ever putting
control in the teachers' hands,
because they're taking it anyway.
You know, they were taking
control the first place,
but as Brian explained earlier,
it was more of a manual cutting
and pasting and pulling things
together using various other tools
and platforms and, you know, I
can remember when I first came
to the Archives, as I mentioned,
I had just been teaching
in the classroom, and, you know I
had come fresh off the subversive
stint of cobbling things together,
but that's what I knew
everyone else to be doing too.
You know, we never
downloaded the lesson plan
or found a lesson plan as is.
We were always pulling it
apart, disassembling it,
putting it with other pieces.
You know, rarely teaching a
lesson plan from start to finish
in one class period, because
(a) it might have been written
for a 55-minute class period,
and yours are actually 42 minutes
because why they can
be even numbers,
I don't know, but they can't.
So, but, you might not want
a full lesson for 42 minutes.
You might want activities
here and there.
So, you know, your
class gets cut short,
you can bump this 15-minute
activity.
You know, so we just knew that
teachers were teaching with chunks
of activities and putting them
together, how they thought worked
for their students in their
classroom, and sometimes,
as Brian mentioned, for
differently for different classes.
You know, for fourth period this
way, for sixth period, this way,
because that's how
they're going to get it,
and so when we started thinking
about creating what would become
DocsTeach, we were thinking a lot
about that, and so we just
kind of made the decision.
You know, it's happening anyway.
So what if we just give
teachers a place to do it.
Let them do it here, and you
know, of course, that meant,
well, this is on our website.
So, you know, how are
we going to do that?
And what we decided to do is there's
sort of a tiered publication system.
So a teacher can publish
an activity.
It's available to other teachers
that have logged into the site.
So you're sort of registering
and logging in and pulling
up from this pool, but if you
just happen to be a casual visitor
and you find, you come to the
site, you only see these activities
that the National Archives
education staff has created.
So they were still there.
The value is there, but it's, you
know, if you were not so familiar
with the site, you wouldn't
necessarily think that everything
that is there was created by us.
So that was one way that we were
kind of able to do it in sort
of address that fear that some
people had of, you know, well,
what is somebody creates a
really bad activity or, you know,
we don't want to look bad.
You know, we're sort
of a model here.
You know, we want to
have a good name.
That's one way we address
that, but I think, you know,
one part of this question
that we want to talk about,
what are the advantages
of giving this kind
of control to the teachers?
Well, you know, for us anyway,
we currently on DocsTeach have 104
National Archives Education staff
created activities, but our users
have created over 20,000 activities
and over 3000 of those
have been published.
So, obviously, big difference
if you log in and what is there,
and the site's always
changing, always growing.
You know, and it's
a way for us to do
that without our staff constantly
creating these new activities.
It also meant a difference when
we were designing the site,
because we put a lot of time into
thinking about the user experience
in terms of building tools, not
writing lessons, and so, you know,
we -- our staff is very familiar
with our holdings and the kinds
of primary sources that we have in
our holdings and how those might,
you know, be useful in the
classroom, and so what we decided
to focus our efforts one, was
thinking about tools and ways
that were broad, you know,
broad themes about how you might
use these in the classroom.
Turning those into real-life
tools on this website,
and then the teachers can plug
in different primary
sources that they find.
So it's putting in their
hands so they can customize it
for their classroom, like
they were going to do anyway,
but now it's up an online and,
you know, a student can click
on this URL without them having
to create the webpage or whatever.
You know, and it also
turned into kind of a tool
that we can use ourselves.
You know, we will use
the site to, you know,
if we do a conference presentation
or a teacher workshop or something
like that, where we're
able to use it.
If we need to create education
materials surrounding an exhibit,
we can use this tool that we made
because it is, you know, template,
really, multiple templates.
There's 11 different tools.
So, you know, we can use it
ourselves in addition to teachers,
but I think, in my opinion, the
biggest thing, the biggest reason
to do this kind of thing is
I will always remember I went
and did a presentation over
in Fairfax County in Virginia.
I used to teach there, and
I went back after I worked
at the National Archives,
and we had created DocsTeach
and did a presentation is part
of their social studies
secondary teacher in-service.
So it's all the middle school,
high school social studies teachers
in Fairfax County, and they asked
me to do a DocsTeach presentation,
but then they had this teacher
that also wanted to, and I said,
"Well, let's do it together."
And, you know, I just always,
it made an impression on me
because he really could
care less that I was there.
He didn't care that I
had help create the site.
He wasn't impressed in
any way, shape, or form.
All he wanted to do was get up there
and show his work that he had done,
you know, and it just really made me
realize that this is his site too,
and all the teachers
that are using it.
This is really their work that
is there, and they really look
at it is their site too, and you
know, I do think probably also,
from a practical standpoint, that,
you know, that can help a little bit
with word of mouth, too, when
you're trying to promote your site.
You know, we did zero marketing.
We didn't promote the site at all,
but you know, so all the growth
that it has seen, which has
been steady is, you know,
I think is in large part because of
that kind of feeling of ownership
that teachers have and they share
their activities, and therefore,
are interested in sharing
it with others.
So I think there's real benefits to
kind of handing that control over,
even though, like I said,
I don't really think --
it's going to happen anyway.
>> Brian Ausland: Thank you.
I'll let you just --
>> Stephanie Greenhut:Sure.
>> Brian Ausland: Just hustle those.
>> Stephanie Greenhut: Yeah,
I'm going to really hustle
because I'm a hustler on the
roundtable, because we do want
to take some questions from you.
So we wanted to and by thinking
about useful first steps for folks
who were maybe getting
started with thinking about how
to do education work with
a digital collection.
So our first piece of advice
is, even though we talked a lot
and are going to talk again in
a second about using teachers
in the process, that does
not mean that you don't have
to do some really basic
curriculum research on your side.
So learn what inquiry-based
instruction is.
If you're going to design a
project that's primarily for sort
of a state history audience.
Like find and do some reading
in your state history standards
to figure out what is covered
in them and what is not.
If you're going to be terrified by
broad ideas like the Common Core,
and you're working with
digital primary sources,
figure out where primary
sources show
up in the Common Core state
standards, and if you're working
with social studies in history,
look at the C3 framework.
It's useful to begin
to develop a sense,
even if you are not an educator
of what is and is not curricular
and what folks might actually be
trying to use your primary sources
to do and an instructional way.
Again, even if you're not going
to be the expert on the team,
I think you have to some of
that knowledge to start sorting
through what is probably a
large group of digital objects
and figuring out which ones
are more or less useful.
We've talked about this
a lot, but also find ways
to involve teachers realistically
but iteratively in the process
of building your project.
So get them involved
in several stages.
Get them to do some review,
give you some feedback,
get them involved in planning.
Check in with them and see how they
think what you've developed is going
and how useful they find it.
We cannot emphasize that enough.
And also, we've talked about
this some already, but be willing
to do some of the heavy
lifting for teachers.
Help with some of that
initial sorting of content
by doing your curriculum
research and also help with some
of the burden of that
active translation.
That is, transforming an
initial version of metadata
into potentially a more student
and teacher friendly
version of metadata.
I know that the folks
on our Education Advisory Committee
have done a lot of that work,
but it's tedious handmade work,
and so you can help
your project get a jump
by learning those skills
behind the scenes.
And Franky answered question five.
So I know we have just a couple
of minutes, but we really do want,
as we said, to take some questions
from the audience, as well.
Yes?
>> Can you give me an
example of providing a context
for metadata [inaudible].
>> Franky Abbott: Sure
do you want me to --
>> Stephanie Greenhut: Take
that if you would like, but --
>> Franky Abbott: Go for it.
>> Stephanie Greenhut: Well, I think
it could mean different things.
In our context, we are -- I have
fellow staff members in the room.
So, you know, there's a
lot of archival speak going
on in our online catalog,
for instance,
and so we pull resources from there.
We pull the digital objects
from there, and we do pull some
of the metadata, but we don't
pull all of it, and in addition,
we will sometimes,
it's not even creating.
Sometimes it's more I scavenge
like nobody's business.
You know, maybe it was in
an exhibit that we had,
and I'll go pull the
exhibit label text.
You know, so it's sort
of identifying, you know,
because our archival catalog
might not have, you know,
we might know the photographer.
We might know the local identifier.
We might know the, you know,
record group series and file unit,
but that's relevant in the
classroom, and I mean, it is.
I mean, it's not -- not irrelevant
entirely, but it's good to know
where information comes from,
for sure, but, you know,
if we could provide a little bit
of historical context
in addition to that.
Sometimes it's even, I will go in,
and we don't really know that much
but we know this is a
photograph from a series of,
you know, Army Corps of Engineers.
I'm not sure.
You know, and we can actually
even just rephrase the metadata
that we have.
So we can say this photograph comes
from a series of photographs taken
at this time from the Army Corps of
Engineers or something like that.
You know what I mean?
So sometimes it's just
rephrasing things.
>> Franky Abbott: As long as
something is a known item,
I would imagine you would find
these in the National Archives,
where it's a fairly famous document,
but the record isn't super full
about what it is, and so,
you know, sometimes students
or teachers might appreciate
a couple of sentences more
of description, or so you have
a portrait of a famous person,
you know, painted in
a particular year,
but the description isn't even
making a speculative connection
between the time period of the
portrait and what was going
on in the person's life, right?
So it's sort of a combination
of those things.
I mean, obviously, we're not trying
to like write a story
that can't say existed.
>> Stephanie Greenhut:
Yeah, we don't have time,
so it is about doing it in
an efficient manner too.
You know, it also can be
renaming things that are --
you know, we have some naming
conventions in our field
that might not translate as
well for a student reading it.
That kind of a thing.
>> Franky Abbott: Titling
is actually the final thing.
I mean, our project
is very dependent
on an item having the
right kind of title.
Because that in a thumbnail or the
thing that will attract somebody
to learn more about it, and so
the title is like "Man on Horse,"
and that man is George Washington,
then we want to get
George Washington
into the title of the item, right?
Or else nobody's going to go look
at Man on Horse in the context
of a George Washington
related primary source set,
because they won't care, because
they won't make that connection.
So some of it is also like
that rearranging of information
in the metadata than it
necessarily is like --
and sometimes it is
building in some more story.
I don't know.
It just kind of depends.
Is that helpful?
>> Stephanie Greenhut: Yeah, I mean,
just the other day, we renamed,
you know we have Act to Alien.
I'm like, oh, that's the
Alien and Sedition Act.
Let's call it that instead.
You know, that kind of thing.
>> Brian Ausland: Or we had --
we did just an activity
just with teachers
where we gave them a campaign
prop from Abraham Lincoln's,
as he was developing a campaign
strategy and run for presidency,
and his political party created
the term "rail splitter."
That's a political term for
him, and they were trying
to paint a certain picture
for the party of the day.
So they have one of their
-- it looks like a hatchet.
Looks like in ax, but
it's just a prop.
It's all wood, and all the data
about it is the type of wood.
Where the burn mark that's on
it came from a fire in 1921
in a warehouse, and so we put it in
front of teachers, and then this is
where I advocate for my prototypes.
We put it in front of the teachers,
and they would see the metadata,
and we had the dossiers and the
curators for that particular piece
and other pieces represented in
the room to watch and observe
as we worked with these
teacher teams,
and we would just basically say,
"What if -- highlight
things that you like."
And our prototype would capture
what teachers highlighted.
Get rid of things that
aren't of value to you.
Assign a standard to this that you
could potentially teach with this.
Assign a topic to this
or a concept you could --
and we would just collect
that data as part
of our testing, and
then we'd go back.
So when we find things
like the teacher --
like some teacher would complete.
The one I love that the teacher
completely erased everything
about it and they put, "This
is what Abe Lincoln used
to kill a vampire with."
And I thought one of the ladies
from the American History
Room was going to faint.
She was so upset that
they typed that in there,
but then the teacher put that in
and explained why you made the
modifications that you did,
and her explanation of
this, fourth grade teacher,
was she said to grab their
attention, and then to move them
to place of understanding
what it is.
>> Franky Abbott: It's curricular.
>> Brian Ausland: Right,
but it was absolutely false,
but that was summer, the
summer that movie came out,
which the curator wasn't
familiar with that movie.
So it was --
>> Stephanie Greenhut: To be
clear, we're not advocating
that type of metadata, but --
>> Brian Ausland: Aside from
pulling your own metadata,
we were also looking at what
teachers find a value or not,
and if they could change of how
they change it, and by the way,
Smithsonian made a very
bold step in their system.
The teachers can write
their own metadata,
write their own descriptive
data for instruction use,
which actually is paradata.
I do want to get into
the weeds on that,
but the resident metadata is still
there for their access and use
as well, but they get
the kind of forward
that the kids see originally.
>> Franky Abbott: Let's
take your question
because you have had your hand
raised since the beginning,
and then people can ask other
questions maybe afterwards.
>> So how would you [inaudible]?
>> Franky Abbott: So ours
are -- our site is young,
which means that we're not
going to be getting the kind
of traffic you are, because
we've only been online
for about eight months, but
our site, since it's been up,
has already brought I think about
25,000 new users to DPLA as a whole,
and that project has seen in the
hundreds of thousands of page views.
I could share some stats with
you if you're interested.
We have done a little bit
of preliminary research
about how often those are coming
from like within school districts,
IP addresses, and things like
that, but the DPLA is sort
of the next frontier for our
project is an assessment of kind
of exactly how the
resources are being used,
and how often they're being used
by random people on the Internet
versus people in actual classroom
settings, which is, of course,
something that happens anytime you
put something up on the Internet.
Do you want to answer
what you know about it?
>> Stephanie Greenhut:
Yeah, sure, I mean,
I'm happy to share
specific numbers too.
One thing I always really
appreciated about going in
and looking at our analytics is that
there's a precipitous drop in July
and August and December, and
it always makes me so happy
because it means that
the audience we designed
for is who is using the site.
So it's great.
We have, you know, we're six
years old, I guess, almost now
and we have had, I'm not going to
compete with Learning Lab probably,
but we've had over
40,000 registered users.
But don't let that number for you.
That doesn't mean we
have 40,000 people active
on the site on any given month.
But those are just our
registered users who sign up.
You know, we're also kind of trying
to think about, okay, how are,
you know, that's one
other thing we've realized
that we do get some other traffic
besides school-related traffic,
and others are using the site just
to find the history enthusiasts
out there because they, you
know, like the search feature.
You know, we're constantly adding
more primary sources to it.
You know, we have, you
know, hundreds of thousands
in our catalog, but we only have
8000 primary sources there, because,
you know, we are really
trying to pick ones
that we think are most useful.
But we're in, I think we've had
over like 12 million page views.
You know, so what I like
to see is the growth.
You know, the year-over-year growth
we've really seen, and again,
it's kind of fun because we
haven't done any marketing.
So it's just spreading
word-of-mouth.
>> Franky Abbott: Did you have a --
did you want to say anything
afterwards, we're overtime?
>> Stephanie Greenhut: Yeah.
>> Stephanie Greenhut:
We're overtime.
>> Brian Ausland: We
haven't launched yet.
It's available.
You can go online.
It's technically in beta.
That launch is in June.
I guess what I can share with
you is they haven't launched
or done anything, and they have over
450 users that have just gone there
and made accounts, and
then their premise was
that just most people would
consume content and resources
and not actually author or create,
which research shows is probably
accurate, but they planned on,
in their beta, just an open beta,
they planned on approximate 75
to 100 teachers creating accounts.
Like I said, they have 450 plus
now, and they thought that about 15%
of those teachers would create
stuff, and they have more like 87%
of those teachers were
creating stuff, and they thought
that they might have some
more, and they have 25
to 50 max learning
collections offered
by teachers, and they have 2000.
So like I said, there
is something afoot.
There is a reemergence and I think
there was something to be said
for such diligence with
the design UI testing,
and it's honed specifically
to allow teachers to come in.
It's pretty low pressure,
and create.
So...
>> Franky Abbott: Thank you.
>> Stephanie Greenhut: Thank you.
Come ask is other questions
if you have them.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.